i'm david reading for reviewer richard
wakeling
with next-gen consoles only a few weeks
away fifa 21 feels like a swan song for
the current generation of sports games
ultimate team is still front and center
as the main draw for many players
but this year's game is also the most
robust version of fifa in series history
bolt of football has been expanded after
debuting last year
career mode has finally received some
much needed new additions and there are
even new ways to play ultimate team
none of this is revelatory but each of
these aspects sets fifa up for the
future
while also ensuring that this year's
game is still worth playing
[Applause]
the goal then for patty man the first
one
of this champions league final oh
they've got the noses in front can they
stay there the latest gameplay changes
aren't immediately obvious when you step
onto the pitch for the first time
new features and attacks supplement the
strong foundations of last year's game
with player responsiveness and passing
also undergoing slight tweaks
there's an immediacy to everything you
do that makes performing sweeping attack
moves a joy to execute
passing has been sharpened up with fewer
instances of the ball missing your
intended target
through balls are also more effective
when playing a runner in behind the
defensive line
with well-timed and incisive passes
managing to find the feet
of on-rushing attackers at a more
consistent rate
ronaldo what a lovely strike
even heading has returned after its
metaphorical absence in fifa 20
with aerially strong players able to
power crosses into the back of the net
with increased frequency these gameplay
tweaks improve upon the core pillars of
fifa 21's on
pitch action while marquee new features
such as agile dribbling
elevate its creativity and attacking
dynamism this new dribbling technique
gives you greater control when faced
with an eager defender by enhancing the
speed
and responsiveness of your player's
footwork it's designed to help you
retain possession
and create space in tight one-on-one
situations emulating the play of
dimunitive playmakers
and fleet-footed wingers it can be a
powerful tool at the feet of the sport's
best dribblers
there's also a palpable learning curve
that applies to using it successfully
and consistently this increased degree
of control is evident throughout fifa
21's other new on-pitch additions as
well
in fifa 21 now you have the option to
choose which direction a player goes
when making an off-the-ball run
this is incredibly useful for moving
your teammates into dangerous
positions to receive a pass or to drag
defenders out of position and create
space for yourself
positioning personality is another new
feature that's designed to allow world
class players
to stand out with their use of
intelligent movement and penchant for
finding space
this essentially heightens the
importance of the positional awareness
attribute
creating a gap between the best and the
rest when it comes to the way
certain players move across the pitch
tap forwards for instance
are less likely to be called offside
able to hold their runs
and penetrate the backline at just the
right moment the art of defending hasn't
changed all that much from fifa 20
however
especially when playing against others
online the tried and trusted strategy of
maintaining control over a defensive
midfielder
is still the best course of action lest
you attempt to tackle with one of your
centre-backs
and leave acres of space in behind for
the opposition to exploit
tackles are slightly more consistent at
winning back possession but with the
deluge of options available to attacking
players
fifa 21 still promotes caution on
defense
players now have the wherewithal to jump
over fallen players
blocking shots has also become more
pronounced allowing you to focus on
staying in front of the opposition
instead of risking a potentially
catastrophic tackle despite these
changes
there's still a large skill gap
associated with defending it's only a
small sample size
but low scoring games are currently a
rarity online with most games quickly
turning into 8 goal thrillers
if you're looking for high octane
attacking football and plenty of goals
fifa 21 certainly delivers but it's easy
to feel outmatched
when defending fortunately you don't
have to go it alone
ultimate team has remained almost
unchanged from last year's game
but co-op is a welcome new addition
you're now able to team up with friends
and earn weekly progress in both
division rivals and squad battles
there are also new co-op specific
objectives that feed into fifa's version
of the battle pass
rewarding you and your friends for
playing together even if you don't play
ultimate team
co-op gives you the opportunity to
engage with it in a potentially less
frustrating environment
as for other game modes volta football
has been expanded since first appearing
in fifa 20.
this unique mode is essentially a more
grounded version of fifa street
ditching the massive stadiums for small
pitches and a focus on skill moves
the debut is a brief story mode found
within volta acting as an introduction
to fifa 21's brand of street football
there are cutscenes and the smallest
semblance of a narrative
but finding any substance is more
difficult than packing cristiano ronaldo
and ultimate team
it's worth playing just to unlock
cosmetic items and a star
player at the end but there are more
enjoyable ways to engage
with volta featured battles are a
notable new addition repurposing
ultimate team squad battles with a
street football twist
by playing and defeating ai-controlled
squads you'll accumulate points towards
unlocking matches against special weekly
teams with unique rewards
the first week for instance gives you
the chance to earn a liverpool kit
and psg star kilian mbappe the latter is
obviously more exciting as you're able
to insert him into your volta team and
hopefully more star players will be
added each week
to give you a compelling reason to keep
coming back to featured battles
fifa 21's new gameplay features also
improve upon volta's flashy football
agile dribbling functions as a
relatively simple way to perform skill
moves
while the new blocking system makes
defending more rewarding
there's an increased variety to volta
this year too with multiple figurations
of matches whether it's
5v5 3v3 walls no walls
rush goalkeeper and so on you'll go from
playing within the confines of a
concrete pitch in a public park in
london
to performing in front of fans in an
official indoor arena in berlin
the size of the pitch alters the way you
play as skill moves become less of a
necessity when there's space to pass to
your teammates
walls add a new dimension as well giving
you the ability to ricochet passes off
their flat surfaces
while the size of the teams forces you
to adapt your strategy
fifa 21 fleshes out volta in meaningful
ways turning it into an enjoyable side
dish that will hopefully become a staple
of the series suite of game modes career
mode has been around longer than any
other mode but it's also faced the most
criticism
for a lack of changes and improvements
in recent years
fifa 21 takes it a step further by
adding a raft of new features
the first of these is the football
manager-esque interactive match sim
that gives you control over the outcome
of each match even if you don't play it
yourself
you can sim any match and watch 2d dots
play it at an accelerated pace
there are contextual prompts to let you
jump in and take control of key moments
like free kicks or penalties or you can
opt to jump in and out at any time
player development has been overhauled
with a revamped growth system that lets
you change the position of youngsters in
your academy
to fulfill team needs when it comes to
the first team
training has also been reworked giving
you the option to set up group training
sessions that can improve specific
players attributes before a game
there's a new match sharpness attribute
that determines how likely players are
to perform in the most crucial moments
of a match
but you'll still inevitably have some
decisions to make come match day
when it's time to pick your starting 11.
this makes career mode more involved
than before
forcing you to manage your players on a
weekly basis and ensure your best are
ready to play
unfortunately the training mini games
you need to play each week just
aren't very fun particularly once they
begin to repeat
it doesn't take long before you
attempted to sim each one but even this
is a bit of a slog as you're forced to
mash your way
through multiple menus each match week
the ui is similarly sluggish elsewhere
with one menu required to scout a player
and a completely separate one needed to
bid for them
that's a lot of unnecessary navigation
for two aspects of football management
that are intertwined
career mode is still a mixed bag then
but it's reassuring that ea has made
some additional moves to try and freshen
it up
if you do grow tired of simming through
training sessions and managing sharpness
fifa 21 is still chock full of other
stuff to do
whether you want to head to the streets
of paris to show off your skills
happen to ultimate team with the friends
or play through a season on pro clubs
this is a substantial package that's
propped up by exciting gameplay that
puts the onus squarely on attacking
football
there are moments of frustration on
defense when the balance doesn't feel
quite right
but then you'll go down to the other end
and score a puska's award contender
that makes you forget why you were mad
in the first place
opportunity and there is the goal to
make it a hat trick
excellence and finishing there for all
to see
[Applause]
you